in the previous episode oh [ __ ]
don't shoot us bro that's right hey hey
your watch man shoot shut up hahaha yes
yes go yes hmm you're all over the news
reports Ethan every cop in the country
will be hunting you they say you're the
origami killer is it true I think my
other self is testing testing my love
for Shawn he wants to know if I'd love
my son enough to save him that means
there's some part of me that knows where
Shawn is the only way to find them is to
go through these trials please
Madison no leave know everything that's
happened there is nothing more you can
do for me you got a hot girl there and
you've got a desert that's a no-no
are you prepared to kill someone to save
your son oh I don't even know what I
want to do ah [ __ ] the pricing and broad
at the other times
all right price go Andrew my name is
Pierre ba and welcome back to the final
trial of saving our son this is my
favorite trial I love all of them I
really don't know what to choose still
uh come on keep knocking on that door
bro yeah what are you a breath oh [ __ ]
why I said a thousand times and I don't
want any junkies in white I'm not a
junkie bro you want a score man you got
a [ __ ] call first
Hey ah you seen either one of these
mother fired before don't forget can't
talk
keep cool I'm cool you better I'd
believe I'm cool what do you want go
tell me what you need sure we can make a
deal
your bros are gonna hate me after this
episode I think whoa what don't blow my
brains out oh I can't [ __ ] up now
guitars oh I have to lay him [ __ ] one
second it's not fair
oh he got me ha ha ha oh no god damn
Punk
oh do something
go die somewhere else why don't you take
his gun
oh my god think bad nice duck bro down
left holy [ __ ]
come on I get say anything my screen
just flickered off and on I play only
one with delay on it did I fail again
Oh out of ammo
all right now excuse me hold it man all
right I give you whatever you want
all right hope I got cash you want some
dope please please don't kill me man uh
I got children you're gonna hate me
bread
he's my girl see guess once Sarah aah
aah don't make it so difficult
Cindy please man I want to see them
again please please don't shoot
I'm a father too but I have no choice
I don't like this choice either I know
your brother think I'm a douchebag that
I think it's the best way to proceed the
story and stuff and it's a pretty cool
moment I know it's not the right moment
but it's pretty cool he's like I'm a
father too by the [ __ ] up it's pretty
badass hello look I'm okay I'm sorry all
right
in the gun grip
how does he do that I didn't shoot him
on my personal playthrough I shot him
for your sake just funning mention that
all right there you go see I don't have
a finger you're about your your opinion
is imbalance we got the address now I
think
we don't even get the entire address
[ __ ] Roosevelt Street
I mean Street is pretty obvious to guess
just don't know they're numbered
it's good that he left his the [ __ ]
DNA all over that [ __ ] good job I'm
[ __ ] throwing up
okay Jesus
fine I'll replay come on please please
don't shoot
we're not kidding we may want to save
father too we're like no killer I'm no
killer look at that green whale
see the first one was more badass so you
regret it now don't yet all right back
to Madison here we go
that it's that I got your information
and the owner of the apartment is marble
Street is a dr. Adrian Baker
he's a struck off surgeon they used to
sell drugs to junkies on the clock
did he make some cash Jim just this
morning were odds that trust me Emily
sang the one in marble street that court
he got caught he did a few months in
prison with struck off the medical
register interesting thanks for the
information Sam I owe you one
hey mad be careful okay cars right why
can't I get off the back bike she really
doesn't give a [ __ ] that is raining no
one in this town gives a [ __ ] about that
ring you can cut off his finger lips
here no lead but it's all I've got
ah alright I like that everyone has
their like investigation going on
I just keep keep being reminded of how
[ __ ] awesome this is I was told that
you could get [ __ ] open without a
prescription
I love betrothing sorry you were
misinformed good mother okay not in my
life I really need your help here I love
betrothing it's my favorite type of dogs
you say so please come
but Ropin is the best I love it smile
Chudley face how he tickles me in the
morning when we take showers together
you're looking for Boudreau Putin my
dear yes I having trouble sleeping
yes but roughly come with me at night I
knew one image of three four axes J four
boxes of the tropen but that shouldn't
be a problem yes would you like a drink
I was just about to have one um no no
thanks
well how qahal helps take the edge off
the pills don't you think anyway we
should drink a toast to our first deal
how about [ __ ] know you creeped me
out old man
alright then chase I want my three of us
I've seen you around here before
who told you about me um vague I can't
remember my brains fried with all these
pills can't tell Dave from night at the
time uh-huh
very interesting well what about the
apartment I heard you had some
apartments for rent
I'm looking sorry darling
those are all booked up shame I was
looking for something round no Street
see what you did there girl
sorry I don't know you're not drinking
no yeah sure I am
don't drink n-no why do I keep man to
click act some trouble [ __ ] why did he
did I warn you about accepting gifts
exactly
why huh oh that evil laugh you saw them
a [ __ ] oh no [ __ ] scabies I'm
alright
son of a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh no he's gonna
cut my BJJ Matthew he claimed he had
come to the senses
another one the goddamn government spa
ah you're interested in my marble Street
apartment happen Paco you must know we
got to get out of here - I did what he
does there I don't want to get my BJT
contantly goo alright
and then the shaky-shaky to be honest I
don't give a damn
just as long as he pays you gotta find
something he can do whatever he likes
but it off with the trick cat I miss
surgery you see my doing it all to
practice I don't have any instruments
here so now use whatever comes to hand I
hope you won't hold that against me no
Wow as soon as you start to do a little
housework someone always kept I'll give
you the bomber here I'll be right back
Bigelow oh no we gotta get out of it I
don't really want my badge a day to be
in portrayed
Tate days all right we need to look at
all right all right no no no forward
forward
yes
take that thing yes good job Manson 10
points hello sir Jen dog I can bring the
wool shut the [ __ ] up gentle it's a doll
I'll gladly meet with you so jammed all
for contribution about that Jantar Lord
thank God for [ __ ] and Jehovah's
Witness all right
come on
James's cards medicine can do it I don't
have my finger to be that
yes oh that evil laugh fledging down a
neck see how it facie okay I need to
change circling
Frankie heck I say ow
[ __ ] you can't see the screen half the
time it's ridiculous I can't see
anything
I want to live goddamn it hush up
that
I just have to react faster spot get out
of there Matt is dead
I don't want to get right so evil
oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ] insane Wow
Kalin alhat Barton's ever gone I can't
see anything
I'm playing with Delana new fennekin I
can't see what I'm doing
Callaham Oh Madison you can't die
no oh he's on this
really you can die in this [ __ ]
hahaha whoops get off me
scuffling son of a [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
huh
good girl Madison I'll call you Maddy
move from now on I can creepy old men
you never trust them
can't even get a Bethel's retinol
whatever [ __ ] it was all right let's
investigate we got any clues
oh the Blue Lagoon huh let's go and
party all right in the next episode like
a beard if you enjoyed subscribe doing
I'm a breath today and I'll see you next
episode of my Apple
you